Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
All right.
Hold on guys. This is Rob and we are picking back up again with Spiderman. Uh,
almost said Spiderman too, with Spiderman.
We're picking back up with miles Morales and Peter Parker.
Now this is kind of a three-pronged event, right?
Like the first time and the first issue they met and the second issue they
fought and this one they team up. So it was kind of a cool,
a cool bit of storytelling here. Right.
But in the instance where they had initially fought each other and things have
kind of popped off and they were sort of coming to coming to terms and,
you know, with regards to this reality,
they're suddenly met by this avatar of a, of Mysteria. Now, again,
this is kind of the robot slash you know,
we're really just straight robot that Mysterio is using.
He is in the main Marvel universe,
but he's piloting this and it's moving around in the ultimate universe. Right?
And so, because of that, as submitted,
it takes down the helicopter that Peter Parker and miles Morales were in the two
of them start to team up to fight up.
Mysterial the problem with this is that that miles Morales has never really
fought anybody like Mysterio before and even Mysterio as he existed in the main
Marvel universe doesn't really exist the same way in the ultimate universe to
kind of give you guys some perspective of the big differences between these two
things. Because I believe by this point, Dr. Strange is dead. Um,
there came a point in the ultimate universe where Dr. Strange fought Dormamuu
and in the main Marvel universe, Dr. Strain has fought.
Dormamuu a multitude of times and won pretty much every single time.
And the ultimate university fights in once and dies. It's it's nuts. Like he's,
he's painfully outclass in comparison to the power that Dormamuu has a,
he kills him with a quickness and that's basically it,
but it happens so incredibly fast because you're talking about Mysterio who
still maintained his ability to create illusions,
despite using a kind of avatar form.
You end up having a Peter Parker who picks up on what's going on. Now.
It took him a moment to realize it because he's like something weird is going
on, right? It's a more,
more powerful strain of the illusion that he normally uses.
But what he ends up doing is conjuring all of Spiderman's villains and the
things that, that miles Morales fears the most, right?
So basically third greatest fears between the two of them.
And with this happening,
you really only ever see the scorpion from the ultimate universe.
You see uncle Aaron,
the Prowler from the ultimate universe it'll make a red for the ultimate
universe,
but you only really see those because those are the only really the villains
that miles Morales has fought so far for Peter Parker. It's,
it's a whole host of stuff, right? It's a whole host of things,
green goblin and Dr. Octopus and all that stuff.
But that's what makes us so bonkers is because of the fact that miles doesn't
really know how to navigate this. Now,
this kind of illusion that Mysterio creates.
That's one of the big things to understand his illusions can be tangible.
If they're powerful enough, they can be tangible.
And that's one of the big differences is that in the early days,
if I remember correctly in the early days,
his illusions were more or less intangible, right?
So he could trick you into believing you were somewhere,
but he couldn't really make things interact with you. And this instance he can,
and it's really kind of been that way for a number of years in Marvel comics,
but Mysterio uses his powers to quite literally have these guys attack, uh,
miles Morales and Spider-Man and Peter Parker, right?
So it was like venom and his carnage has all these guys,
and this is an incredibly dangerous because these are forces that miles isn't
used to facing off against.
But this is one of the big differences here is that miles hasn't really faced
off against mysterial before. But at the same time,
this kind of magic doesn't necessarily see exist inside the, the ultimate.
You know, now this may seem like it would naturally work against miles Morales.
He's basically being exposed to something that he hasn't really seen before,
and wouldn't really know how to navigate those waters,
but instead of doing what Peter Parker seems to be doing here,
which is kind of overthinking it to a degree instead,
Myles actually manages to get the upper hand and basically incapacitate Mysterio
temporarily. You know,
if for no other reason than to basically take down his avatar form and then
essentially, right, like a destroy that, that it,
because miles picks up on the fact, this is the reason why it's happening now.
Again,
this is one of those instances in the ultimate Spider-Man comics where people
were a little finicky, they were like, I mean,
I have a hard time believing that miles would be able to pick up on this and
Peter Parker. Couldn't,
you're talking about two characters from two different realities who navigate
waters differently. There were, when this, when this story first came out,
there was one group of people who looked at this and said, okay,
the only reason miles be able to figure this out on his own is because Ben is
writing it and Bendis is pushing miles.
And does it really wants to him to be like the new ultimate universe Spider-Man
and of what use would his character be if he didn't have some kind of caveat
over Peter Parker from Peter Parker in general,
like even from the main Marvel universe, it's one of these interesting concepts,
one of these interesting quad Myers, but again, you know, with,
with regards to Mysterio,
he's one of these villains whereby all standards of measurement.
He would've gotten the upper hand on miles Morales because what makes Mysterio
is, uh, you know, his, his powers.
So incredibly potent is he's much like mastermind or somebody like Charles
Xavier, not in so much as the powers he possesses, he's just an illusionist,
right? He doesn't really have to let pithy or anything like that,
but much like those guys,
his powers can totally envelope you and convince you that you're somewhere that
you're not right. Mysterial gets his hands, it's on you.
If he can convince you that you're a world away, you know, and, and you're in,
you know,
some pirate land and you're fighting against pirates or something like that,
whether or not you're able to actually pick up on that are two distinctly
different things, right? Creating that illusion. If you're of sound mind,
you'll immediately know that something's off, right.
Regardless when everything kind of pops off,
Peter Parker actually ends up taking off. He doesn't leave the universe.
He just goes to explore it.
And where you end up having the ultimate to arrive here on the scene with the
miles Morales. Now, one of the big things that goes on here is again,
because these characters were designed to be a lot more toned down than the
versions that we saw in the,
the ultimate universe that Tony stark doesn't really know how to navigate this,
this technology, right? Like in the main Marvel universe,
he would have picked it up right off the bat and just been like, okay,
so here's what's going on with this instead. And the ultimate universe, he,
his intelligence is a little more grounded, right?
So it's not as though he's just wildly out there as intelligent as a story needs
him to be. Instead, it's a little more grounded here.
So he recognized that in so far as this, an exceedingly, you know,
advanced form of technology, and that is an avatar is basically being used by,
you know, this ministerial guy to control it, you know, control this,
this avatar version from someplace else.
But in terms of being able to reverse engineer it almost instantaneously,
that doesn't happen here, right. That doesn't really take place here.
Now from miles part, of course,
he ends up asking Nick fury where the other Spider-Man go and fewer responses.
He went out there to explore things. And that's the nature of this, right?
When you're,
when you're someone like Spider-Man and you face off against Mysterio and you've
gone through as illusions.
So many times the biggest struggle he has here is trying to figure out whether
any of this is real or false. That's the biggest struggle he has at the moment,
because, you know, you've got to kind of think of this from Peter's perspective.
He was in his own universe, he was facing off against Mysterio,
found himself yanked through a portal,
ended up in this new reality where he's dead.
There's a new Spiderman that took his place. Uh, and that there's a,
there's a Nick fury there, you know,
who seemingly allow the two of them new team up and then mysterious avatar,
piers. He ends up facing off against all of his villains,
even though they're illusions. And then of course,
miles Morales ends up destroying that, that avatar.
And now Peter is basically exploring in his mind,
all of this could be the illusion. And that's the truth of the thing, right?
That's the truth of the thing here, when you're facing off against material,
this could all be illusion it's entirely possible that Bendis could have ended
this story. And it was all just one big, huge illusion created by, by Mysterio.
And it would work. It would be believable because he's done it before, right?
That's the advancement of mysterious illusions is that it just,
it screws with your head so incredibly badly. But as we know,
Peter Parker is actually in the ultimate universe.
And so we basically start tracking different things down and he goes to the
place that would have been his apartment. He has a funny art Cornerstore.
He asked him like, how long has this been here? She's like, I don't know,
how long have you worked here? I've worked here two years, you know?
And he's like, okay. So there was never an apartment building here, you know,
like there, like there was never an apartment here.
And so basically he never stayed here.
The other thing that ends up happening after he beats up some guy who runs into
the place in Robinson is he asked her for, you know,
for a tablet that can help him access the internet. And when he does,
he finds an article that the Spider-Man in this universe really did die here.
And that it really, that everybody really knew that he was Peter Parker,
that he was a high school student from Queens.
And so it's one of these things where it's kind of like,
I really am in a universe, run dead. The other part of that is of course,
she has this little necklace around her neck.
And of course it's her way of paying respects to Peter Parker.
Spider-Man and then he's like,
you need to tell me exactly what happened to Peter Parker in this universe.
And so what we end up doing is we basically end up picking up, uh, you know,
some period of time later with aunt Mae and with Gwen Stacy from the ultimate
universe. And Peter Parker shows up on their doorstep, right?
Like literally just shows up there.
And this is one of the most amazing things here.
It's one of the most amazing moments,
because this is Peter Parker coming to grips with when Stacy,
who is still alive in this universe and aunt Mae and having to face the fact
that in their mind he's dead. And so it was kind of like, wow,
like this is one of those things is a hyper emotional story.
If you're a Peter Parker fan, right. It's, it's kind of nuts. It's Peter Parker,
re-encounter stirring, uh, aunt Mae and Gwen, Stacy. It's kind of nuts.
But with that being said, guys, we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to come as explain,
make sure you guys are the sub button to become part of the Rob core.
If you guys enjoyed this video, make sure you drop a light.
Now we'll catch you all later, Bruce.
[Inaudible]
[inaudible].